he's going to get the wall here might
have a sidewall no he's good he is oh
what's he doing what oh bro like a
double jump oh my gosh and you went for
the manual quarter circle forward dash
into a parfait
are you kidding me four you're not going
to sweep that
there we go pushing towards the wall
oh this is gonna be a lot of damage to
the mix
up oh
but because of the keeper that messed
things up
oh my god are you serious
three
yep damage
i was gonna work for somebody
maybe not and it's crazy because you
know he's usually the bigger character
right
yeah oh my god he's dead
how did he miss
oh my gosh i don't know what just
happened too but do it again two
it's my noses combos it's a combo maker
here we go
love me
oh the
unblockable doesn't get worse black
lovely now
what's going on right now what a point
no punishment one
oh he's out of breath oh my
he's finally trying to find a way in fgl
the spacing immaculate catches himself
stepping with the homie move here we go
pressure down jab throw bro change the
misery are you serious
oh punish launch
there we go
this is how it starts
oh
my
god
[Music]
[Music]